well actually I have a niece who is 13
years old who is with us here and talked
a little bit about it it turns out that
at least in the u.s. children that age
know a great deal about biology and they
know what proteins are and I know what
mitochondria are so I'm not sure it's as
difficult to explain as seems to be
implied by the question how do you
explain it to a 13 year old but one of
the I think the best thing is to take an
example of what we were able to do and
one of the things that make cells work
is that they have little transport
systems they have molecules that have
basically two feet and they walk along
rails which are called microtubules and
they transport things from one end of
the cell to another and in fact the
Nobel Prize in medicine and physiology
was given for studying the vesicles the
things that these little engines carry
from one part to another but they just
looked at the top part here for the
vesicles that are carried and we figured
out how a couple of molecules which are
basically two globular domains like this
that are connected by a coiled coil can
actually walk and they walk the way we
walk in the sense that they put the left
foot taller than the right foot forward
left foot four and the right foot four
and so that's one example of how
although people had studied that I'm
experimentally and had static pictures
of what they looked like they couldn't
figure out how they moved their feet
they sort of throw their feet forward
and it's that what is one application of
the methods that we developed that it
can teach us how molecular motors as
these are called
this is these are called kinesin
how they work and